but Randy kosa Jason Knight if you want
the most violent minute you've ever seen
in Combat Sports tune in to look at his
lip I know I feel so bad he always gets
so destroyed in these fights man here's
here's what's about Jason Knight
phenomenal
Jiu-Jitsu ridiculous on the ground if
from The Ultimate Fighter like even with
Savvy vets or whenever they toss him
these young L he'd submit all of them
he's such a beast on the ground just
goes nah I'm going to fight like the
redneck Diaz bro that's why they call
him hick Diaz look at his lip my
goodness I know it's but it got better
look that's after uh stitches and stuff
looks way better yeah he's such a Savage